welcome back to Sky News some breaking
news Penny Morden is running to be the
next prime minister of the United
Kingdom she's just tweeted uh less than
a minute ago saying I've been encouraged
by support from colleagues who want to
Fresh Start a United party and
leadership in the National interest I'm
running to be the leader of the
conservative party and your prime
minister to unite our country deliver
our pledges and win the next general
election hashtag PM for PM uh bringing
back that uh catchy hashtag from earlier
in the summer of course she ran early in
the summer came third behind Rishi sunak
and Liz truss and of course therefore
didn't end up facing the party
membership portion of the leadership
race and she's clearly announcing her
her leadership ahead of the other
suspected front-runners not that Rishi
sunak or Boris Johnson won't soon
announce but uh is the first one of
those three favorites if you look at the
betting markets or the three favorites
if you look at public Declarations of
MPS supporting them they have the most
support so far penny more than coming
about third in that list of public
displays of sports in the in their mid
to high teens of MPS who've come out
tobacco so far whereas Rishi sunak has
over 50 MPS so far publicly supporting
Boris Johnson somewhere in between a
reminder of course of the process from
here by 2PM on Monday all of the 360
Tory MPS will have had to back one of
the candidates that they want to go
forward you need a hundred to get over
the line from the first stage and of
course uh 360 or so MPS about there
there won't be more than three a maximum
of three and it seems like the three
most likely based on public declaration
so far will be penny more than Rishi
sunak and Boris Johnson and a reminder
that penny more than now the first of
those three Front Runners to publicly
declare she will be running saying she's
been encouraged to do so from support of
her colleagues who want a fresh start a
United party and leadership in the
National interest